So what's a training set? Well a training set is
a set of all of our inputs, like pictures of
people, paired with a label, which is the correct output.
So in this case, yes, this person is credit worthy.
>> [LAUGH]
>> Versus another example.
>> You can tell I'm credit worthy based on my curly hair.
>> Purely on the hair.
>> Versus someone who has no curly hair and therefore
is obviously not credit worthy. And if you get bunches
and bunches of examples of input and output pairs, that's a
training set. And that's what's going to be the basis
for you figuring out what is the correct concept or function.
>> I see. So instead of just telling me what tall means, you're
going to give me lots of examples of, this is tall, this is
not tall, this is tall, this is tall, this is tall, this is
not tall. And that's the way that you're explaining what the target concept is.
>> Right. So if you want to think about this in
the real world, it's as if we're walking down the street
and I'm pointing out cars to you, and non-cars to you,
rather than trying to give you a dictionary that defines exactly
what a car is. And that is fundamentally inductive learning as
we talked about before. Lots and lots of examples, lots of
labels. Now I have to generalize beyond that. So, last few
things that we we talk about, last two terms I want
to introduce are candidate, and testing set. So what's
a candidate? Well a candidate is just simply the, a
concept that you think might be the target concept. So,
for example, I might have, right now, you already did
this where you said, oh, okay I see, clearly I'm
credit worthy because I have curly hair. So, you've effectively
asserted a particular function that looks at, looks for curly
hair, and says, if there's curly hair there, the person's
credit worthy. Which is certainly how I think about it. And
people who are not curly hair, or do not have curly hair
are, in fact, not credit worthy. So, that's your target concept.
And so, then, the question is, given that you have a bunch
of examples, and you have a particular candidate or a candidate
concept, how do you know whether you are right or wrong? How
do you know whether it's a good candidate or not? And that's
where the testing set comes in. So a testing set looks just
like a training set. So here our training set, we'll
have pictures and whether someone turns out to be credit worthy
or not. And I will take your candidate concept and
I'll determine whether it does a good job or not, by
looking at the testing set. So in this case, because
you decided curly hair matters, I have drawn, I have given
you two examples from a training set, both of which have
curly hair, but only one of which is deemed credit worthy.
Which means your target concept is probably not right.
>> So to do that test I, guess you can go
through all the pictures in the testing set, apply the candidate
concept to see whether it says true or false, and then
compare that to what the testing set actually says that answer is.
>> Right, and that'll give you an error. So, by the way,
the true target, the true target concept is whether you smile or not.
>> Oh. That does make somebody credit worthy.
>> It does
in my world. Or at least I, wish it did
in my world. Okay. So, by the way an important point
is that the training set and the testing set should
not be the same. If you learn from your training set,
and I test you only on your training set, then
that's considered cheating in the machine learning world. Because then you
haven't really shown the ability to generalize. So typically we want
the training set to include lots of examples that you don't,
the testing set, I'm sorry, to include lots of examples that you don't
see in your training set. And that is proof that you're able to generalize.
>> I see. So that, and that makes intuitive sense,
right? So, like, if, if you're a teacher and you're
telling me, you give me a bunch of fact and
then you test me exactly that bunch of facts, it
doesn't, I don't have to have understood them. I just
can regurgitate them back. If you really want to see
if I got the right concept, you have to see
whether or not I can apply that concept in new examples.
>> Yes,
which is exactly why our final exams are written the way that they are
written. Because you can argue that I've
learned something by doing memorization, but the
truth is you haven't. You've just memorized.
Here you have to do generalization. As
you remember from our last discussion, generalization
is the whole point of machine learning.